allez selon vous à quoi correspond ce
chiffre on démarre tout de suite 79
oui madame ah c'est l'âge de Denis c'est
pas ça alors pourquoi je suis devenu
papa
à 79 ans
qu'il soit facile c'est que je trouve
que pour l'enfant c'est quand même très
compliqué il va pas connaître beaucoup
son père et c'est très égoïste en vérité
plus vite
ton père que t'as pas connu je pense que
ça peut faire des grosses séquelles moi
qui c'est qui est d'accord
voyez Benoît je sais pas si je suppose
que vous avez été amoureux dans votre
vie mais ce que vient de dire Philippe
c'est très juste vous voyez quand vous
rencontrez une femme à n'importe quel
âge elle a envie d'un enfant d'ailleurs
70 ans on peut encore en faire
plaisir à la dame si elle le souhaite
la dame qui vous dit que ce sera pas des
jumeaux
alors lui pour compliquer les trucs dans
mes franchement effectivement alors
regardez écoutez son interviews
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc forcément c'est un mythe mais il
est quand même fatigué
[Musique]
ça va plus le traumatiser tu vois
et à ce qui paraît ces enfants sont pas
hyper heureux d'accueillir la nouvelle
quoi le dernier sachant que le premier à
plus de 51 ans
moi je trouve ça un tout petit peu comme
tout le monde vénère De Niro ici tout le
monde le m'énervement
on peut se poser la question et faire
deux heures de débat là-dessus mais
c'est un chouch choquant quand même
enfin tu vois à un moment donné ce que
voilà alors qui c'est qui est d'accord
avec Laurent alors moi-même c'est trop
tard 80 ans
ils ont besoin de leur papa aussi pour
grandir alors après on dit toujours ah
bah oui mais tu peux avoir 25 ans et
passer sous un bus oui certes enfin
c'est moins probable normalement on
passe un peu plus de temps quand on est
plus jeune avec son enfant pas une
tortue imagine de tente qu'il qu'il a je
parle pas très inquiète à vous pensez à
la famille vous pour récupérer le gosse
oui et Philippe les autres enfants ils
pensent aussi qu'il y a un héritier de
plus mais bien sûr
je m'en fous parce qu'il fait pas partie
de ma famille
voilà c'est une belle conclusion on
remarque c'est vrai en tout cas en fait
beaucoup de bonheur c'est ce qu'on peut
dire je vous dis à se rappeler quand
même qu'il a eu des enfants qui sa
première femme qui s'appelle dianabot
c'est déjà pas mal il a eu des jumeaux
avec le mannequin tout qui est Smith il
a eu deux autres femmes avec l'actrice
chanteuse great side Tower que j'ai très
très bien connu parce que c'est une
copine de Guillaume Durand et ma dîner
souvent ensemble d'ailleurs à ce
moment-là ils habitaient à côté de à
côté de là au niveau du melon
d'être cocu
c'est quand il était avec elle qu'il a
rencontré la fameuse
qui est très sympa une fille une femme
vraiment sympathique voilà mais enfin
bon en tout cas on leur souhaite
beaucoup de bonheur parce qu'on est
gentil dans cette émission n'est-ce pas
oui Jean-Michel on est gentil on s'est
mission parfois
on y croit vache